I don't do any email at all which is how
I do my work when I'm actually working
the only time I do email is when I fly
even though it's what I'm supposed to do
because when I'm on the ground that's
the time to do this so your answer and
your advantage is time you need to work
the people that have money there's three
variables three pillars time money
talent talent is hard to control money
you don't have yet time is your only
friend what you do between 7:00 p.m. and
3:00 in the morning will ultimately
probably be the variable of your success
now if you lack talent you can work for
the rest of your life you're not gonna
win so you need to be smart about that
and then there's the strategy of what
you're building if you're building a
piece of [ __ ] you've lost but the thing
that's most controllable in sales is
time you got it how are you interesting
there was a company that I looked at
couple several years ago that had a
similar concept and I loved the theory
it's hard it's why ooh burn Airbnb are
special you need to always obsess about
both and the thing that I've seen most
two-way marketplaces because everybody's
the uber and airbnb of X right they over
index on one side or the other and then
it breaks the tension of making both
great is all you've got so you have to
literally literally you basically have
to be a perfect parent of two children
you actually have to love both of them
equally so whenever you feel and one of
the challenges of loving both your
children equally is they live their
lives and you know and when the one
seven one six maybe that's six year olds
having a tough time and you're spending
80% there
because the seven-year-olds okay but you
better not spend too much time because
then if you don't spend too much someone
a seven-year-old in my crack and that's
a two-way marketplace you have to figure
out what the health of both are and you
have to equally have from strategy real
strategy against both and then you have
to adjust on a day-to-day basis if one
is underperforming yeah no no nobody's
ever won two-way marketplaces by going
global right away though you always lose
they raise too much capital it's hard I
loved the way you explained it like
hundred in the air I'm like okay good
start you know now the question becomes
what's the addressable market how big
should and could you get here if that
answer is 40,000 meals a day you got a
lot of work to do if that answer is 1500
not so long before you start thinking
about where else my intuition is it's
closer to 40 thousand and 1500 so you
got a lot of work to do
yeah but but it's about keeping the eye
on the ball and about caring about both
sides and by doing back the time
unscalable things you know everybody
wants to find that perfect ad product
that gets awareness but they don't want
to go to like the farmers market and
shake people's hand or like people tried
and true things always work like you
still have eight good friends and family
members who don't use your product
that's insane
fix that you should have 108 people
every day do you know what I mean though
but you know what I mean that's
important that's important I think
people forget everybody's thinking about
scale and they're not looking of what's
in front of them like every single
person you went to school with every
acquaintance like you know everybody how
many people are using it every day raise
your hand how many people have used it
you got work to do I look at that as
awesome like that's fun that means you
have a lot of opportunity you know what
I mean cool thanks you're welcome
Hey
from seal jobs how are you good how
would you describe the best possible
startup CEOs let's go Connor that's a
thing um so I'm big on sales in general
I'm open for me personally and this is
not a tried and true answer it for me I
love people that have sold stuff in
their life there's something consistent
about it that's really worked out for me
in the last 20 years you know and they
can be tech nerdy you know they they
they you know the kids I liked coming up
the game with like ripped music from
Napster put on CDs and sell in school so
it was a little tech it was a little
product right
I was baseball cards and lemonade some
people were candy you know so like sales
um I I try to figure out as hardcore as
I can do they need to do this because
they can't breathe if they did anything
else
or are they doing it because they think
there's more money in it or because it's
cool now I think that 95% of the startup
founders that I meet are doing it for
the other two things they're either
doing it because they think the most
money is there cuz they get seduced by
the exits they read about or because
it's now cool to be a start-up founder
so I hate the current state of startup
hate it I've not been investing at all
for the last year and a half nothing
I've made a couple of big investments
and things that I'm really involved win
but the kind of stuff that you guys are
mainly doing I'm not even taking
meetings because I feel like we have the
greatest fear of fake entrepreneurship
ever in the US it just became so big and
powerful and popular everybody did it
and in other places it was good for the
country the region it was the right
thing to do which is both true the
problem is it brings a lot of people
into the game that aren't meant to be so
my biggest thing that I'm looking for
the best entrepreneur and founder is are
they an entrepreneur and founder or are
they acting like one and that takes and
that's too hard and unlike the advice I
gave downstairs about well hire and fire
you can't unfired a hundred thousand
dollar investment you know and so I
think that I look for
people that are driven patient and not
fancy the amount of people that are
founders of companies who go skiing on
the weekend who go to every marketing
meetup event who takes selfies with
micro celebrities we're in we're in such
a [ __ ] era basically Club promoters
have taken over entrepreneurship it's
the truth and everyone the reason
there's giggles and head nods as we know
it just became cool you know what a
start-up tech entrepreneur look like 10
years ago not like this you know I'm not
meaning that I'm sure there's some in
this room but none were attractive none
were cool it was some nerd ass [ __ ] like
I got into it pretty early and I was
like were tough I mean it was like you
know like and I was friends with
everybody but this was like geek culture
web 2.0 were geeks period and the story
if you were a start-up founder 2006 you
were a geek geek geek so um you know
what else I'd look for just a I know a
lot of people are building tech
companies with no tech person in their
company they're an entrepreneur with an
idea and they think they can outsource
the development and they're in the tech
business so there's just a lot of fake
[ __ ] going on cool
welcome hey how are you good
love it and the and the content would be
used in the classroom or outside the
classroom okay okay
yep whatever right good yes you don't
you do one of two things you either
emphatically aggressively through your
sheer will and being not politically
correct get them there or you wait until
they get there you can't fight the
market now couple questions and I don't
know the school system here very well is
there anything within the system that
won't let them do that
like does the teacher actually make the
decision or the she or he have to play
in the rules of the superintendent the
government like is there something else
that's not letting them use it it's not
that they don't believe it's at that
they can't because they could have an
issue if something happens
but it's getting there so can you give
them the iPad why you haven't thought
about it yet no okay and you don't have
that that's okay and what about and do
you guys have the money to do it right
so I would reach out and so I would go
home tonight and I would send an email
to Samsung and Apple and Microsoft and
Google and I would ask one of those
companies so Windows Microsoft tablet is
not doing great you might be able to get
50 of them for free
go ask and then give it and now you've
eliminated one of your problems but a
lot of startups will go out of business
because they were too early and so one
of the naive things that all of us do
including me is we think it's gonna
happen faster to them it actually
happens so you got to be careful with
what I heard really quickly here to make
sure you're not too early and if you are
how do you adjust to stay alive until
the market comes to you welcome do you
rock no okay next oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
brother
d-roc [ __ ] you up Jesus to rock yeah I
got it I got it too much to the light
in this globalized world yes USA
yes that's a good question my intuition
is right now and I don't by the way the
answer is I have no [ __ ] idea comma
based on what I'm seeing him doing right
now he's more worried about getting jobs
to stay in America for very old school
construction manufacture he's worried
about the states that he has to win in
his next election so he's more worried
about Ohio and Pennsylvania and Michigan
and so I don't I don't know but I'll be
honest with you with the amount of
European startups that have had real
success in the US market President Trump
might be your last problem do you know
what I mean well be careful anything can
happen
Russia and China have proven that the
Internet's have borders and I take
nothing for granted
especially being born in Russia so you
know I I wouldn't rely on that I would
remind you to be more practical which is
there are not that many winning startups
in Europe dominating in a US market
environment I think your bigger problem
is the other US startups that we're
doing what you're gonna do much more
than the president United States
well I think I think a lot of it is um
talent you know I think I think that one
advantage that the u.s. has is that the
most talented kids from America all
migrate to Silicon Valley and then you
basically have this ecosystem of a lot
of talented engineers and proud of
people that are teaming up it's just a
talent game and it's very easy to move
within the u.s. from to San Francisco so
the talent
I actually think plays out I think
entrepreneurship is inherently rewarded
in the United States while it's still
historically in Europe it's finally
chipping away so I'm so happy to be here
but historically failing in America
though tough is not a deathblow failing
in Europe is a scarlet letter and that
has been the death of entrepreneurship
over time in in Europe I think that uh I
think there's infrastructure and history
of consumer behavior you know the
Internet is just though you see
interesting things like the UK market
has a healthier ecommerce business than
the US market in a lot of ways but I
think I think a couple of factors
venture capital money is consolidated
which has given a lot of people the
ability to build businesses that don't
have to be profitable and have been able
to get through and build very big
businesses and the infrastructure of
communication the biggest websites in
the world the far majority of them
outside of Chinese based companies are
based in the US and China is a closed
door so nobody's really doing much there
it's insular nationalism whereas a lot
of people are doing it now that being
said Spotify SoundCloud there's amazing
accomplishments that have worked over
there but I think you're going so macro
I'm way more concerned about the micro I
think you can't focus or be crippled or
by that you just need to focus on even
being able to win that game if that's
your ambition you know the good news is
if you win that game that means that
you've raised a lot of money from a lot
of very important people who will deploy
that political and financial capital
against you staying alive like to win in
the u.s. you've built a billion-dollar
company unless you're looking to build a
very practical small business and then I
would diversify period then you don't
need the u.s. necessarily do you know
what I mean
you need the US if you're going global
and building a billion-dollar
you need the u.s. to build a ten or even
100 million dollar business you got it
hey man how are you and my question to
you is since I'm yeah for us how do you
decide whether or not to go for a
business since itself for example of
customer bump stops and says hey but
can't you do this custom for us and
we're like that could be possible but it
takes away from our core mission it's so
classic that is gonna be predicated on
how good you are I am those are
decisions I can't make there's no
tried-and-true there's been plenty of
people who did a side-project
customized which did two things gave
them the money to stay alive and showed
them something they never thought up
which then built their biggest product
and there's been companies that got
distracted and became an agency and a
client service business and mr.
opportunity both have happened a
trillion times no guy from the US who's
been successful is gonna tell you the
right answer you're gonna make those
calls and your success is gonna be
predicated on it you know the best part
about that is that's the way it should
be
that's what capitalism and meritocracy
is how good are you did you make the
right call because they're both right
but they're not both right for you good
question is will you make the right call
when it matters see we'll see but that's
the answer
don't be crippled by it and more
importantly don't do it they're little
they're literally potentially both right
and if it doesn't come to you right away
it's only gonna get harder the more you
sit on something it gets harder not
easier people think like they're gonna
figure it out you're gonna figure it out
by tasting it should I eat this cherry
will I like it if the right strategy is
to [ __ ] eat the cherry right then
you'll know truth is you should probably
do both
if we can but if you can't that works a
couple of times but if it then person is
ringing at your door it's like yeah but
then they tensed person's ringing at
your door you need to figure out why the
[ __ ] they're ringing at your door maybe
the right move is to actually build a
business that does do that and is highly
profitable so that you have cash when
the world dries up of cash and you're
not at the mercy of VCS and raising
money but you actually made cash cuz you
were an agency for four years and then
your 37signals and jason freed which is
they were an agency and they convert it
into their product and they became a
huge business people are fancy people
when they have nothing say dumb [ __ ]
like yes but the economics are in
building our own product not in services
you don't have anything yet but the best
way to have something is actually do
something that's bringing you money I
think so that's cool
my question for you was how do you how
quickly minutes great how do you expand
in new cities without being there
yourself to promote it by being there
yourself through either you or the
person you trust the most in the world
the end when Travis was expanding guber
he either went to the market or Ryan
graves went to the market cuz he trusted
him the most and he did that for five or
six markets until Patrick in Chicago
showed that he was worth trusting and
now Patrick and Ryan and Travis
everybody's trying to scale scaling the
unscalable is how you get to the point
of scale
so either you're number two is got
Belgium on lock and you can go to Paris
or she or he can go to Paris but don't
hire somebody on a whim because you
don't know what you're dealing with and
then you lose or you can win yeah but
you're risking it I don't think opening
a new market is worth the risk cuz it
can take you down
so what I like to do is over hire
I would probably hire an extra person or
two here and really start testing and
tasting and understanding them to be
ready to move one of them there and if
you're only in one market I'd probably
move to the second market you got it
hi Gary how are you I'm really good I'm
really grateful to be here
Thanks perfect we created a solution for
businesses to make group meeting
scheduling a lot more easier okay and my
question for you is how can you use
storytelling in a more b2b setting okay
let's go back to the product what are
you solving and the problem of
scheduling meetings but more like for
businesses because for example I'm a
consultant yes and if I have to work in
the company I need to meet with the CEO
meet with the marketing advisor and they
all have really busy schedules and with
my tool I can just send you one invite
it takes 30 seconds and we find the
perfect moment to have that meeting are
you integrated into Google calendars API
of course Google Calendar office 365
exchange iCloud all of the big players
and we even have like really smart
plugins that work in your Gmail in your
outlook one click and that's it got it
look it takes all that data surfaces up
what the right yeah opportunist it takes
the data in your calendar but also your
location your travel time your personal
preferences like it's never for I on top
to make like all the stuff that your
personal assistant we do we do that for
you and just big the right if you put in
the inputs or through only API
integrations yeah we use the information
that's in your calendar already got it
um and so you're trying to figure out
how to build top of the funnel awareness
for the product yeah but I really like
the concept of storytelling and I would
like to use it somehow in our b2b
marketing strategy right so storytelling
in the way that you want to do it comes
in the form of making a three minute
video that is a scene out of a sitcom
that shows how your utility fixes the
problem yeah so what I would do you know
what I would do is like I don't know if
you guys have the office as a show good
so I I would make a four minute videos
here storytelling you make a four minute
that starts with you know an executive
like you just tell the story right the
executives like [ __ ] I need to see Carl
but we're sit like you just show the
problems or it's a scene of two
administrative assistants having a beer
and saying you know what really [ __ ]
sucks when every when you've got a
schedule all three senior vice
presidents and they're all in three
different markets you basically got to
show a scene from a movie or a sitcom
then you make the video then you run ads
on Facebook against employees of the
companies that you're trying to sell to
and then people will see the video and
then they'll share it with the decision
maker not just tangible black and white
b2b marketing employees of segmentation
in facebook is one of the great
underused marketing tactics can a b2b
world so for example if you were selling
a b2b product and you're trying to get
to the CIO you make a video that the
opening line of the video is does your
CIO know because if you do that if the
person who watches it is in a different
department but they think it's
interesting they click one button and
they share it with the CIA
this is linked ins miss right now and
Facebook's opportunity and if you care
about storytelling then you go for humor
or or sad there's you know in
storytelling there's tried and true
emotions humor fear sadness
inspirational you know paint a picture
show me right two people walking into
office getting coffee
nine o'clock how's your day gonna suck
yours gonna suck why he's traveling to
14 cities and I have nine meetings to
make me to two secretaries dying gal
talking did it did today some nerd kid
comes up he's like why don't you use
what's name a company planner why don't
use planner the [ __ ] is planner did it
everybody's happy
got it yes cool by the way real quick
that's how Dollar Shave Club created a 1
billion dollar company one video now
that's hard you might have to make 11
videos before that happens and that
might cost you so much money you go out
of business but that's what it takes
I am since you liked predictions for b2b
companies what are the big players b2b
has the same opportunity and has the
same platforms as b2c but not every beat
every not every product works for b2b
the way does for b2c so for example
snapchat snapchat is very effective in
the u.s. it's very big obviously it's
lost some steam because Instagram copied
features but it's still much bigger I
mean people are so so funny people are
so lazy then I go it's dead
yes it's dead to hundreds of millions of
active users super dead you know might
not work for every every single you know
company because the target of who
they're trying to get to might not be
using snapchat but if they are so for
example if you guys decided the people
that actually would use planner are
actually 20 to 30 year old admins now
you're saying maybe they are on snapchat
now you know that there's an open API
net there's an open platform now where
snapchat allows you to make custom
filters it's one of the great deals of
all time you want to win in the US
market it's $5 for 20,000 square feet
for an hour so I don't think this is
open for here yet but if it was or when
it was I could have put a filter for my
b2b company overall 300 people here
let's say 80 of them used it for all
three hours that events were going on it
would've cost me $15 and the time that
it would have cost me to create a filter
and the 31 coolest people here
youngest most tech-savvy would have seen
my filter and that probably would have
been worth $15 or I promise you when
they dope
up here and now it's getting even more
interesting there's an enormous Liebig
match for your national team and you
know the 15 biggest bars or pubs are
gathering places and now you buy it
there and that's just general awareness
that's just brand marketing so nobody's
thinking that snapchats good for b2b but
what if the biggest conference for
secretaries and admins in the world is
happening in Hong Kong and you buy your
filter there do you see people he I set
it downstairs and I'll say it here the
key back to your first question my man
the key for if you're an entrepreneur
startup founder of a young company you
have to be the architect you have to be
the general contractor you have to be
the mason the plumber the garbage man
the reason I am so fearful of startup
founders right now is everybody wants to
be the architect you know you gotta be
the you gotta be the executor the reason
I have so much bravado around my social
media strategies is I'm a practitioner I
use it every day every one of them lots
of them always you know and that's a big
deal so you know to be good at you know
marketing you have to be doing marketing
you have to try these things you know
and so I would say that Facebook is
number one two three four and five I
didn't I don't you know what's funny
people think I predict I don't predict I
just move quickly when it's happening
yeah after after 40 [ __ ] million kids
downloaded musically yeah I mean here I
mean by the way the greatest advantage
of being in Belgium is you get to see
the future and just do it here now not
every time not Pinterest doesn't always
become huge here but it's worth the risk
you should move fast on every US
platform every time because all you need
is one of them to be the next Facebook
or Twitter or Instagram or snapchat or
whatever but you know I know Twitter
never popped here as much but like all
you need is one and it was worth all 15
failing because the 16-time paid for all
the other times come
got it that's how I predict I'm just
usable and then I look like a genius he
did it I'm like yeah you didn't talk
about social camera you know we don't
you know
remember vine for but here's what's
funny it's like a hit show vine is dead
but I got a lot of value out of mind for
the 13 months that it mattered I got
what I needed out of it
everybody wants all these platforms to
last forever but they don't want every
television show to be number one to run
commercials you just run commercials
when it is number one pretty cool yep
[Music]
because and so I'm asking me for example
for ginger walls how can I sell myself
to them I mean like how do you stay
there how do you provide value for what
you're being paid for first of all the
fact that you care about that already
puts you way ahead of everybody else so
that makes me happy um I don't know I
think you know you know I always say
sell your truth right you heard that
like I agree with you I think it's funny
that we're in this era right now where a
lot of people are getting hired just
because they're young or they've got pay
dirt and hits some magic on some sort of
social media account and then the
traditional companies just think that's
the magic there it's very hard to
generate money from anything not just
social media from print and radio and
television so I I think that being
upfront with the client is always the
best i I think I don't have a great so
are you looking for the short term how
do I jet like just very tis the real
question just a very short term
practical answer of like how to drive
business for them or you go more macro
when you say paying for content you mean
the generation of creative well Belgians
are paying tons of money for content yes
so your impressions wrong like there
there's a ton of companies paying
creative agencies money to produce
pictures and videos to put out on social
networks maybe not how many companies
have you talked to no so one more time
when I want to really know what you're
asking because you're you're dancing
which is cute but I want to answer your
question are you asking for people to
sponsor creative on your page like what
are you asking me I can't answer you if
you don't ask me fine yes and they say
no okay there's small businesses in
America too lots of small businesses say
no let's start from the beginning
how many restaurants have you asked for
money tell me the number bunch isn't
interesting and how many restaurants are
in Belgium good go ask all of them even
if you're a hundred even if you're zero
for a hundred you need to figure out if
you're zero for 40,000 how much are you
asking for can it be performance-based
so for example can you if what are you
pitching them because if you go into a
restaurant say the following
hey Mack I cover your restaurant I like
your restaurant let's make a deal you're
gonna pay me 500 bucks for three months
to put out some original content but I'm
gonna assure you 15 clients because I'm
gonna do a call to action for a free
beer and then you'll make it up or if
you're just walking in saying hey Mack
pay me 500 bucks for pictures and videos
on my Facebook page he may say no but if
you say I'll give you the money back if
you don't get 15 maybe he'll say yes
maybe what you're trying to sell isn't
interesting to them also maybe you
haven't asked the other 7,000
restaurants and you just serendipitously
got 0 out of a hundred but the next
batch of hundred you get 11 or maybe
you're asking for too much
I believe you so what are you asking for
and how much are you asking for yes and
they're saying now and you're 0 for 100
they just don't believe you you got to
figure that part out you know and that
happens to youngsters all the time
youngsters always ask me how do I sell
because they think I'm too young I'm
like you don't you don't convince people
you're not gonna walk in with a gray
haired wig you know you know so I think
remember don't try to sell somebody
who's not sellable you're dealing with
small traditional businesses a lot of
those people are saying no to their own
children to do Facebook marketing let
alone you coming out of nowhere and
wanting a hundred fifty bucks for it
got it here's what I would do I would do
a post on a single restaurant and do
unbelievable write-up about the single
best drink or meal they have and push
hard your entire audience about go in
Friday and order this and then I would
call Saturday morning and find out how
many of those they sold if you call on
Saturday morning to Mack and go hey Mack
did you sell a bunch of french fries
yesterday he's like [ __ ] we did you're
like no [ __ ] dick I did that different
strategies
I'm done so we are frustrated by the
state of advertisements from the client
or from other agencies yep
what are you selling them no I
understand thisis what do you do what is
that we're just we're how what
which are you get inspired by commercial
messages and so I personally hate your
business model even more than theirs
and I'll tell I'm being honest with you
but I could be wrong but I've looked at
incentivized marketing for 40 years
I hate the idea that the only reason
you're watching my video of this is
because you actually want Spotify
credits and that's what I believe
the model of incentivizing advertising
looks like so I'm probably not the guy
to give you the model to like convince
people because I've talked a lot of my
clients out of it if I'm reading what's
right I feel like that's what I'm
hearing now if every business that I've
seen in that world has short-term
victory and long-term down and so again
if you just think about the thesis of
what you're saying you're asking a
consumer to consume an inspirational
message or whatever you want to call it
that was very clever and I liked it but
the only person the only reason that
person is watching especially are you
your own platform your own app or things
of that nature that's even crazier
the only reason somebody's downloading
it is to go through that motion to sell
their time in return for something they
actually want the last thing they're
actually giving the advertiser is their
attention they're just you're just
pouring out that transaction of course
you do no no you have nice numbers but
are you actually getting people to buy
my grapefruit soda is a very different
thing from a branding standpoint because
the intent of the interaction was not
for that I hung out with this person cuz
I wanted to date that person there's
nothing good happening here so by the
way by the way let me just say this I've
been wrong about a lot of things but as
you can tell I'm very passionate about
this because I've looked at it for a
long time I'm just not a big fan of
incentivizing
advertising consumption because of
something else I want you to buy my
Greek food [ __ ] soda not to get
credits to buy an Apple iPhone
but it's that well it's the engine that
drives it right yeah so so I think the
media so you're trying to convince media
spending agencies to drive dollars into
you guys yeah me look I mean I I would
definitely go through very hardcore
performance-based agencies if you go to
the media centric people they're gonna
be more than the branding right I think
that people that are real digital
performance media buyers they'll look at
metrics and and make a math decision not
an emotional decision and I think you'll
have more opportunity there correct
correct correct you're gonna win that
game because people have to you're
forcing them to watch the whole video
before you get the free stuff which for
me as a marketer means you didn't
accomplish the goal but for all the math
marketers you appease them in the short
term yeah I you know and I want you to
win but I can't [ __ ] you how I feel
about it yeah I appreciate it but go to
the performance only because that's
what'll go for it thank God me too
I like it is that right that would've
been even worse than that I like it I
like grapefruit flavors mm-hmm so I I
understand the circumstances I actually
don't think they're any different right
you have certain you have experience you
may have you know some wins under your
belt like you may have different things
that they don't I'm not worried about
what one has won what doesn't have my
questions what are you asking
specifically like what what do you want
to do so you were doing what got it and
you decided to start your own brand
awesome and so what's happening
well good so what what maps to think
sometimes you want a cake
sounds like losing players is that good
enough
sometimes yourself talk to yourself I
get it here's what's happening it's
interesting because you're you're you're
very interesting to me here's why you
either were an entrepreneur and you
suppressed it to do the practical thing
and work in corporate America or you
were kind of maybe 50/50 right like you
had safety but you also like you had
entrepreneurial tendencies you weren't a
hundred percent pure like for me I would
die well you know like I can't breathe
if I'm not entrepreneurial and I mean
since I was like nine I mean that's why
I got very bad grades in school this
wasn't it school now I was disaster in
school and the immigrants got A's that's
how you got out you know so what's
interesting is the reason you're letting
outside forces seep in is because you're
not hot when you're a hundred percent
you don't give a [ __ ]
you're crazy to begin with the whole
thing's crazy right so if you're in
between I would tell you this let the
results and the way you feel speak the
last people you should be listening to
is anybody else if you feel it you know
what I mean I mean now if your whole
circle if your spouse if your parents if
your siblings if your best friends are
all pushing hey hey it can get hard what
I would say is find an outlet for
support keep hanging out with these
people right offset the voices you need
the other voices watch content from
other people you know like but it is a
it is a black it like if you need that
so I don't I don't consume anything
because I don't need ideas or
Reformation or motivation from anything
I keep insular but if you're feeling it
and I understand because you're
practical right you feel like you feel a
huge sense of responsibility and so
you're always thinking what could go
wrong I would remind you a couple things
did you have a fairly successful
corporate career being a marketer good
this is going how long has this been
going
and how's it going good it sounds like
you're just a winner and so if you
happen to lose here which we all do I
have a funny feeling you're gonna be
able to go get a job no [ __ ] it's why
you did it but you have to understand
upside versus downside the upside is you
build a whole life around something you
want to do and it's the best and you
make more money and you're happy and
you're doing your thing
the downside is the other thing you left
so as long as you're not worried about
what everybody says about you losing
here if you have to go back then you're
risking nothing yeah you got it yeah too
much based on how good you are so it's
it's it's in parallel with quality
quantity access curve of too much is
when you're not good enough for some
reason the numbers show me that even
though I'm saying the same thing over
and over as you guys can tell in here
especially the ones that are closest to
me I'm so improv it comes so natural to
me as a communicator I can still say it
in different ways
paint different pictures and it makes it
interesting and maybe this analogy
finally got you to understand or maybe
that analogy finally got you understand
it's the reason I continue to do Q&A
left to my own way I'm gonna get into
the same patterns when I realize that I
started forcing more of this because
you're forcing me into new ideas new
thoughts teaching me different different
analogies right so it's too much if you
have nothing new to say or not or
nothing new to say or nothing to say
that's relevant in a new way
yeah I mean like I don't notice how I
don't there's not a lot of blog posts
for me I finally figured out my team
they transcribe and I've got some blog
posts of my words but I'm not a talented
communicator and a written word so I
don't do it right so you also have to
know your skills in communicating a lot
of you have a lot of good ideas you
should be taking them taking your phone
recording it and putting out in the
world like you know how a lot of you'd
like you have good idea like first of
all like the amount of people here who
have a lot of good ideas and aren't even
recording it for themselves to use later
just letting up that's what that's
really one of the other big reasons I
started doing daily be I was like [ __ ]
there's a lot of good [ __ ] I'm saying
and I mean for me not just for you that
I'd like to have and then it became like
man all those things I said back in 1996
1999 2003 mm you think I've got a good
thing going now if I'd been doing this
from the beginning
[ __ ] you would think I did predict the
entire like I [ __ ] I mean that now
there's some things that are were wrong
I remember for four months I was
massively passionate that all email
would become video but that would be fun
too I'd like this like you know like
when everybody puts me too high in a
pedestal I'd play that video and be like
what about that you know you have to
balance you know but uh I don't I think
the market decides too much and I think
some people have one move and I think
some people have 1 million moves just
got to figure out where you sit in that
some people are better off writing a
very thoughtful ten thousand word essay
once every two months that everybody
looks forward to cuz they're a great
writer they press you know you could see
I'm fast like I can real business advice
like I'm really in it I can do this and
I'm [ __ ] a lot of times it's really
right to like I'm a good entrepreneur
right but but I can't write an amazing
twenty thousand word expert do you know
a sad I am I can't do that some of my
thoughts I never fully get there you
know they get to 73 percent but I don't
have I don't the ability to make it deep
enough because I'm just you know and and
so sometimes it takes me two or three
year document to over create how many of
you heard that for me document over
create great so that took me a long time
to get to maybe like seven years but it
was the thing that really unlocked it
for a lot of people
just for a lot of you my point on
creating content is instead of trying to
think what you make just document
everything you're doing if you act do
you know that two or three of you if you
just documented the journey of figuring
this out that people would watch your
video on YouTube every day of you trying
to figure out the school system and that
in itself which is what would build your
business it's the story it's the it's
the journey of an entrepreneur the
legacy that I'm creating with dailyvee
[ __ ] you know cool that's gonna be when
there's 10 years worth of my every day
especially if I pull off very big things
I would love you know you know fun it
would be to watch the three years before
Drake became famous everything he did
know fascinating that is you know cool
it would be to watch everything like a
special Steve Jobs perfect its I'm not
at that level yet but I I would tell you
that I'm in the same place right now you
know Steve Jobs had Apple then he got
kicked out then he had a failure called
next failure and then yet came back to
Apple and it all went crazy right would
have been awesome if he did a daily vlog
for that last year of next that
in-between year and that first year we
launched the iPod [ __ ] we'd all watch it
everybody so there's a lot you know and
by the way even if it never changed her
business do you know much fun it would
be for your granddaughter to watch you
do it really think about life you know
inspiring that would be she'd be like
damn grandma was a hustler I want to be
one too no really right like you know I
don't like you know much fun it would be
for me right now to see my dad making $2
an hour in 1979 waking up at 4:30
driving working 15 hours in the liquor
store and coming back that's cool
so I don't think we think long-term
enough what it really means you know I
look at stuff now I'm like oh man I was
so young oh [ __ ] I was pretty fat you
know like like you know it's cool that's
why I do it yeah yeah let's do it Hey
ten years was 15 years ago I started
that I was lucky enough to invest in
darts nerds candy know what nerds like
that's super cool I love nerds candy yep
so give me I want to make sure I'm
interpreting your question the
adversities that lead to the successes
or I want to hear give me an example of
one of yours so I can use that as a
proxy to give you my answer adversity I
agree I think it's a natural do you know
do you know how many people have
committed suicide in a tech startup
community last five years and there's
not a peep about it tons
I don't lean oh of more than a handful
and and I know that I'm not looking for
it I know that war in one of the leading
kind of like startup you know
entrepreneur schools in the u.s. suicide
rate has doubled each year with the
growth of this because entrepreneurship
is on the pedestal and everybody thinks
it's easy it's the loneliest work it's
his emotion like you know how hard that
is it's on you there's no blaming
anybody if this wins you if this loses
you that's lonely as [ __ ] that's why I
keep saying lately I've been saying you
know what the best game is to be the
number two you get a lot of the money
you get a lot of the action but you
don't get that right Rick I was just
number two Rick [ __ ] up
CEO I was just a CLO I told Rick you
know you know yeah I mean you know yes
sir please yeah so I'll tell you why I'm
dancing going no no I think I appreciate
what you did
the reason I'm dancing is because I
don't think you know how purebred I
really am
I'd be lying to you I don't want to lie
to you I feel like I you deserve an
answer and I don't think I have one for
you
zero the day I stopped being a student
my whole life changed forever I've never
had one bad day when I'm in pain I go to
sleep for five minutes and I wake up the
next day and I kissed the world I don't
give a [ __ ] about entrepreneurship I
care about the health of my parents and
my children and my wife and this thing
called entrepreneurship is easy as [ __ ]
I'm the best you understand so the
reason I'm dancing is I don't I didn't
want to give you such a ridiculous
answer that I know does not map I'm
gonna end up being the guy my man like
when it's awesome that what I die I'm
gonna be on the [ __ ] pedestal at the
tippy-top and so that's not everybody so
for me to give that answer is very
difficult because I have pain there's
always problems my brother walked in and
said I quit I've Crohn's disease I want
to leave vaynermedia it's all on you
that's not fun that's hard but it took
me eight seconds to absorb it and then I
started smiling and saying good it's
just who I am
so for me I was dancing because I can't
even give you an answer because every
day's hard and that's the best [ __ ]
part of it and so that's my truth
[Music]